[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler d'une
des plus grandes angoisses de l'humanité
je veux pas parler de la guerre je veux
pas parler de la crise climatique ni de
l'illettrisme ou de la douleur chronique
je veux parler évidemment de quelque
chose de bien pire
la lourde menace que font peser les
emojis
sur notre langue française
43% des Français dans une enquête menée
en 2017 estimait que les emojis
appauvrissent ou menacent notre langue
il redoutait par exemple une perte de
vocabulaire parce que les emojis
remplaceraient les mots
ils évoquaient aussi une perte de
nuances sémantiques une perte de
compétences en orthographe et en
grammaire voir il y avait une crainte
carrément que les emojis remplacent
complètement notre langue écrite
tout se passe comme si dans nos têtes il
y avait un combat entre d'un côté les
emoji de l'autre la langue française
ce que je vous propose de faire ce soir
c'est d'organiser pour vous ce combat
combat dont je serai évidemment
l'arbitre parfaitement impartial
ce combat il oppose donc d'un côté les
emoji
donc vous voyez ici le caractère
proprement horrifique
et de l'autre notre cher langue
française si amusante
et si guillaume est
passons tout de suite au premier round
ce premier round je l'ai intitulé
l'épreuve de l'oral
en effet si on réfléchit un petit peu
deux secondes et attention là je vais
vous livrer une vérité profonde
accrochez-vous les emojis ça n'existe
qu'à l'écrit
les emojis ce sont des pictogrammes
c'est à dire des petits signes visuels
qui ressemblent à des objets
pour vous puissiez un petit peu frimer
ce soir dans vos dîner mondain je vous
donne l'étymologie de pictogramme pique
tous l'image gramma l'écrit ce qui
correspond d'ailleurs au mot emoji qui
en japonais est une contraction entre
eux qui veut dire images et emoji qui
veut dire lettre ou caractère d'écriture
donc le nom même du signe nous indique
qu'il s'agit d'écrit et uniquement
d'écrit ce que confirme d'ailleurs
l'étymologie
alors il faut m'expliquer comment on
dessine qui n'existent qu'à l'écrit
peuvent menacer une langue parce qu'une
langue c'est avant tout de l'oral en
linguistique on dit que les cris c'est
une transcription de l'oral les cris
c'est pas la langue c'est une toute
petite partie de la langue donc comment
dessine qui n'existe qu'à l'écrit
pourrait menacer une langue dont les
fondements sont oraux réponse de votre
arbitre impartial il ne le peuvent pas
donc à l'issue de ce premier round les
preuves de l'oral la langue française
l'emporte 1-0 vous pouvez applaudir la
langue française
1 0 pour la langue française
très bien ok ça menace pas la langue
dans sa globalité ça menace pas l'oral
mais néanmoins ça peut menacer notre
langue écrite et ça dans le pays de
l'Académie française ça peut faire un
petit peu flipper et à juste titre parce
que notre langue française écrite elle
est une histoire elle est très riche
elle est très belle elle est très
complexe ce serait fort dommage qu'elle
soit abîmée par ces petits signes
colorés
donc il faut qu'on recarde un petit peu
le combat on va passer maintenant
uniquement à l'écrit à l'écrit et
uniquement à l'écrit qui est-ce qui
l'emporte entre la langue française et
les emojis
on va commencer par notre deuxième round
donc qui va
consister à faire passer à nos deux
belligérants les preuves de l'histoire
si on regarde un petit peu l'histoire de
notre écriture les premières traces
qu'on en a elle date de 3000 à 4000 ans
avant notre ère et c'est ce que vous
voyez ici c'est à dire un système
pictographique c'est un système dans
lequel des images renvoient des objets
au bout de milliers d'années d'évolution
l'être humain a mis au point des
alphabets vous voyez un petit peu ici
l'évolution
des alphabets dont notre alphabet qui
sert de support à la langue française
l'alphabet latin mais alors pourquoi on
a fait ça mais tout simplement parce que
le système pictographique de nos débuts
de nos origines il est très lourd et
très inefficace imaginez le nombre de
signes qui vous faut mémoriser pour
représenter sous forme de petits dessins
tous les objets qui vous entourent c'est
une infinité de signes c'est absolument
colossal notre système notre alphabet
latin nos 26 lettres qui renvoient à des
sons permet de transcrire une infinité
de combinaison de son et avec ceci de
fabriquer des terminaisons des mots de
façon assez simple et assez efficace
même dans d'autres systèmes d'écriture
comme le chinois on est passé d'une
langue écrite purement pictographique de
60 000 caractères à aujourd'hui
6000 signes qui ne sont plus seulement
pictographiques mais qui combine
différentes façons de décrire
tout ça pour dire que des systèmes qui
fonctionnent uniquement avec des images
pour écrire on en a eu on les a
abandonnés à cause de leur inefficacité
cet abandon il s'est fait sur de longues
années naturellement ça me semble être
un argument de poids une fois encore
pour dire que pour ce deuxième round la
langue française l'emporte à nouveau il
y a donc 2-0 pour la langue française à
l'issue de cette épreuve de l'histoire
merci pour elle elle a gagné l'épreuve
de l'histoire n'empêche que il y a 50
ans il y avait pas d'emoji aujourd'hui
il y en a ça a bien un impact sur notre
écrit et évidemment ce serait stupide de
le nier
alors si on regarde ce qu'on fait à
l'écrit en fait il y a deux cas de
figure qui se présentent
le premier cas de figure c'est celui où
les emojis vont remplacer des mots
comme vous le voyez ici
c'est une des choses que je peux faire
le deuxième cas de figure c'est celui où
les emojis ne vont pas remplacer des
mots mais vont accompagner des énoncés
pour par exemple indiquer comment je me
sens ou pour illustrer sous forme d'une
petite histoire graphique ce que je
viens d'écrire
donc pour continuer notre combat il faut
qu'on traite de ces deux cas et on va
commencer par le premier cas le cas où
les emojis remplacent des mots c'est
notre troisième round et je vais
l'appeler l'épreuve du Grand
remplacement
humour douteux je vous l'accorde
donc pour répondre à la question est-ce
que les emoji menacent de remplacer les
mots de notre langue je vous propose un
petit test vous avez normalement une
phrase qui s'affiche
ce splendide public est constitué
exclusivement de personnes magnifiques
essayez dans vos têtes de remplacer les
mots de cette phrase par des émotions
alors vous allez très vite vous rendre
compte que c'est compliqué qu'est-ce que
je peux remplacer en gros
peut-être les noms communs encore que là
dans ce cas de figure public c'est
difficile à représenter par des émojis
mais par contre je peux pas remplacer un
adjectif comme splendide je peux pas
remplacer un adverbe comme exclusivement
ni un verbe comme constitué je ne peux
pas remplacer des déterminants les
prépositions les pronoms etc bref avec
des emojis je ne peux quasiment rien
remplacer du tout
allons plus loin imaginons que les
emojis et c'était une des angoisses
présentées dans dans l'enquête dont je
parlais en introduction imaginons que
les emojis remplacent complètement notre
langue on se passe complètement de la
langue française écrite pareil je vous
propose un petit test je vais vous
montrer une séquence d'emoji que voici
essayez de l'interpréter
il s'agit en fait du résumé du film
Spider-Man
je suis désolé pour ce ou celle qui
n'ont pas vu le film parce que j'en
révèle la fin pardon ça se finit pas
très bien
mais vous voyez bien que c'est compliqué
en fait l'interprétation des emojis
comme ça c'est très compliqué on peut y
arriver mais c'est très c'est très
difficile et c'est beaucoup plus simple
de le faire avec avec du texte
donc là encore à l'issue de ce troisième
round du Grand remplacement la langue
française l'emporte à nouveau 3-0 pour
la langue française
il nous reste à traiter du dernier cas
le cas où les emojis ne remplacent pas
des mots mais accompagne des énoncés
qu'il faut savoir déjà c'est que ça
c'est le cas le plus fréquent si on
regarde des masses de données c'est cet
usage là qui est devant et de très très
loin en valeur absolue d'emploi
et ça ça a toujours été le cas depuis
l'apparition
des emojis ou plutôt de leurs ancêtres
donc ça c'est des pictogrammes qui sont
apparus dans les années 70 en même temps
que le chat alors certes il ressemble
pas vraiment à nos emojis d'aujourd'hui
mais on a quand même un petit air de
famille
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
pourquoi dès qu'on s'est mis à
communiquer par chat
pourquoi les pictogrammes sont apparus
dans nos conversations
ben c'est parce que le chat si on y
réfléchit un petit peu il y a beaucoup
de recherches là-dessus c'est donc ce
mode de communication où je tape sur mon
clavier je suis derrière mon écran et
mon interlocuteur et en même temps que
moi derrière son écran et son clavier on
échange en temps réel ces conditions-là
de communication sont en fait très très
proches de ce qui se passe à l'oral sauf
qu'on est à l'écrit
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on quand
on se parle à l'oral
et bien il y a sans cesse de système qui
sont en interaction il y a ce que je dis
les mots que je prononce mais il y a
aussi ce que je fais mimique mais gestes
mes intonations et tout ça participe au
calcul du sens je vais vous en faire la
démonstration en prenant sans plusieurs
fois la même phrase en faisant des
choses différentes autour je m'excuse
par avance pour mes talents d'acteurs
qui sont proches du néant attention je
me lance ce public est génial
première version deuxième version ce
public est génial
j'ai évidemment dit exactement la même
chose dans les deux cas mais
l'interprétation que vous avez faite a
complètement changé dans les deux cas
puisque je n'ai pas fait la même chose
autour de ce que je disais
mais alors les emojis dans tout ça et
dans les emojis font à l'écrit
exactement la même chose que nos gestes
nous intonations et nos mimiques à
l'oral c'est exactement le même effet de
sens
est-ce que vous allez dire que quand
vous avez une interaction en face à face
à l'oral vos gestes vos mimiques vos
intonations viennent appauvrir ou
menacer la langue que vous utilisez
il me semble que non donc il y a pas de
raison de faire ce reproche aux emojis
qui jouent en fait à l'écrit exactement
le même rôle que nos gestes nos mimiques
et nos intonations
à l'oral
donc pour ce quatrième et dernier round
d'ailleurs je voulais pas dit pardon
mais il s'appelait Laura de la
coopération il y a effectivement
coopération c'est à dire que on a deux
systèmes qui en fait fonctionnent
ensemble et
ne s'oppose pas en fait il y a pas de
combat dans ce dans ce quatrième et
dernier round ce dernier cas de figure
il n'y a pas de combat donc il y a 0-0
et j'ai le plaisir du coup de vous
annoncer le score final
à l'issue de ce quatrième round qui est
de 3-0 pour la langue française
merci pour elle
donc
plutôt que de s'inquiéter de la menace
que ferait peser ces signes sur notre
langue on pourrait peut-être se réjouir
de l'inventivité et de la créativité
dont fait preuve l'être humain parce que
pour la première fois de notre histoire
nous réunissons dans un même contexte du
texte et de l'image pour les faire
interagir de façon complètement inédite
mettre du texte avec des images pour
exprimer comment on se sent on n'a
jamais fait auparavant
donc pour finir il y a pas de menace
pour la langue
au contraire ce qu'on fait est plutôt
intelligent et très malin et créatif et
constructif
pour vraiment finir je puisque tout le
monde est maintenant plus familier avec
les emojis je vais tout simplement les
laisser un petit peu récapituler
ce match au sommet
et je vous laisse là-dessus je vous
remercie de votre attention je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée merci